Now, how to do we achieve max-min fairness? One approach is
via round robin scheduling. Where, given a set of cues, the
router simply services them in order. The problem here is that
packets may have different sizes. So if the first queue had
a huge packet, and the second queue had a little packet,
and the third queue had a medium sized packet, then servicing
these queues in order obviously isn't fair. Because the first queue
would effectively get more of its fair share, because its packet
just happened to be bigger. An alternative is
to use bit by bit scheduling, where during each
time slot, each queue only has one bit serviced.
This, of course, is perfectly fair, but the problem
is feasibility. How do we service one bit from
a queue? A third alternative is called Fair Queuing,
which achieves max-min fairness by servicing packets according to
the soonest finishing time. A Fair Queuing algorithm computes
the virtual finishing time of all candidate
packets, which are the packets at the
head of all non-empty flow queues. Based
on these virtual finishing times, Fair Queuing
compares the finishing times of each queue
and services the queue with the minimum
finishing time. So the queue whose packet
has the minimum virtual finishing time is serviced.